in this movie it's like the seven year  itch cycle of a relationship i'm sorry i  don't know what came over me please let  me fix it  again  you've got two characters that are  literally stuck with each other you live  in my body you live by  that odd couple relationship was what  this movie was always going to be about  as a progression from the first one  excuse me  it's like living with an oversized  toddler they have had enough of each  other  they can't be together they can't be a  part then he's far too selfish venom  just wants to be the hero i am a  predator we should be out there snacking  on bad guys watching tom as then in the  navy was so much fun  that is a red one you need to come away  now  [Music]  [Music]  you